we appear to be approaching potentially
two more arrests of failed former
president Donald Trump first and
foremost is that Fannie Willis in
Georgia is stepping up security and
precautions for this next uh season so
to speak of announcing indictments that
will start in July and run through
September there is the belief that Trump
is getting indicted there but separately
there is a rolling stone article Trump's
lawyers warn him get ready to be
indicted by the feds the former
president has angrily complained in
response to predictions that if the
justice department is going to charge
him then what about Joe Biden what about
Joe Biden and the article says some of
Trump's lawyers and advisors have given
the former president an unwelcome if not
unexpected message in recent weeks you
should expect to get indicted this year